die grünen haben zwei fehler gemacht
erstens sie haben die homöopathie
debatte verschoben und zweitens sie
haben mich reingelassen bin aus der
zukunft kommen heute und habe die
homöopathie debatte dabei überraschend
viele bei den grünen finden also
mittelchen gut deren wirksamkeit nicht
belegt ist und die nur ein placebo
effekt beinhalten müssen die dann das
klima paket der bundesregierung nicht
auch gut finden die gar nicht also auch
ein placebo effekt ist ein effekt wer
heilt hat recht dass meine meinung ist
funktioniert einfach
sie laden die homöopathie lobby bezahlt
die homöopathie lobby glaube hier gibt
es einfach nicht es gibt eine starke
lobby gegen die um über die aus meiner
sicht sie glauben dran glauben es
funktioniert einfach also ich persönlich
glaube überhaupt nicht wo ich bin selber
naturwissenschaftler
ich glaube nicht drohe aber es
funktioniert trotzdem arena trug laut ja
was sollte die krankenkasse noch
finanzieren und schornsteinfeger für
jeden zum anfassen beweisen
aber wenn ich daran glaube dass das
glück bringt es wurde für markt der
völker katze ist kennt man ja mach mal
die hände auf ich habe für alle globuli
dabei
[Musik]
dieses springen
ich habe mir in denen sie den streit in
die grünen tragen würde dann treten sie
jetzt den grünen bahn streiten uns ja
aber gegen dieses angebot nämlich
globuli die helfen da schon aber
gestritten wird doch immer noch also
hier hinten geht es noch ab oder da
können wir den klimawandel nicht einfach
verschieben
wer cool also ich würde mal sagen wir
schieben einfach mal angeschrieben die
erde einfach ein paar zentimeter reck
und dann wird es auch wieder schlechter
wird habe ich übrigens auch globuli
dabei
da ist nix da schon bei uns hat nix also
wird geklärt wie es gehört dass es
ordentlich aussieht aber nicht thema
wird zur seite geklärt und es wird jetzt
erst mal die richtigen räume gebracht
und zu diskutieren und dann kommen die
bäume die außerhalb der öffentlichkeit
statt da muss man denn überhaupt
diskutieren bei etwas wo es
wissenschaftlich erwiesen ist dass es
über den placebo-effekt hinaus nichts
bringt entweder ist man die partei der
wissenschaft oder nicht natürlich immer
die wissenschaft etwas gibt so eine
wissenschaft und sonne wissen schaffen
das sagt die afg beim thema klima auch
ist so eine wissenschaft und so die
eltern
das ist so lichtjahre von den zweck das
ist ganz geile zeug ich sage mal so
chocabeck war es zu krass
jetzt interessiert nein nein also meine
drogen zeit habe ich in der jugend
hinter mich gebracht
es war eine sehr intensive und gute
erfahrung das hat mich auch
weitergebracht glauben wir vielleicht
heilsteine oh ja man muss ihn nur fest
genug werfen
da sieht man doch noch die alten grünen
hervor kommen na klar startbahn west wo
sind die guten alten zeiten denen nicht
man früher da hatte ich noch angst vor
ihnen echt wann ist aus dem tiger ein
kätzchen geworden wird das passiert
immer so mit der zeit
leck mich am arsch ist dass hier nach
harmonie soße ich gehe jetzt zur grünen
frage ob sie noch drogen kommt hört die
so richtig ball an
[Musik]